it is appropriate at this time to answer
some questions we made the call last
night on the respective twitter accounts
pft and chris sims and uh we've got some
chris we've got several questions to get
to so let's get right to it on this
thursday morning and the first question
this is a good one not to be confused
with the bad ones that we got joseph
redfearn 2 wants to know
who plays for a different team first dak
prescott of the cowboys or oh aaron
rodgers the packers don't want you
it's just a matter of time before they
trade you who leaves first
uh aaron rodgers
this is a no-brainer i mean mike we've
discussed this a lot i i don't think
it's crazy to think that aaron rodgers
might get out of the green bay after
this year
you know i don't think that's going to
happen with dak prescott even if he
plays the franchise tag game that he'll
be there at least for two more years but
ultimately i just don't think the
cowboys are going to let dak prescott
out of their grasp right now why he's
just about to reach the prime of his
career so
uh yeah i think with aaron rodgers the
way it looks to me right now he's got
two more years at most in green bay
maybe it's one and he's out of there
yeah look i i agree with you and when
the packers first traded up three weeks
ago today to get jordan love in round
one of the draft when the dust settled
on that we looked at the cap numbers
that would up that would hit the green
bay books if they trade him after this
season the first thought was well they
can't do it but then when you compare
the cap hit if he's on the team to the
cap hit if he's not on the team and the
fact that you saved 22 million in cash
if you trade him he very well could be
traded after this year but until the
cowboys signed dak prescott to a
long-term deal i'm not ready to assume
there won't be a kirk cousins type of a
situation and i press stephen jones the
cowboys co last week on this issue of
what if you don't get a deal done by the
july 15 deadline for doing a long-term
deal with dak prescott but we're looking
at a salary cap figure of 31.4 million
this year next year it goes to 37.68
million and the cap could actually go
down next year because of the reduced
revenues from the pandemic i look
that's a lot to pay to dak prescott and
then after that it's a 44 raise over
37.68 million it's 54 million for 2022.
he could be on the open market by 2022
but i'm with you chris i think that
aaron rodgers gets traded after this
season but i think there's a chance both
of them end up playing for other teams
not one or the other but i think both
could end up elsewhere
well i don't think i
you know i don't know i guess i would be
shocked what dak prescott just because
and again i mean all the things you say
makes sense definitely
but
there's just not you know again starting
franchise top 10 type quarterbacks don't
grow on trees they don't and i think
there's a real affection from the jones
family and the cowboys organization for
what dak prescott is i do now again i
don't know what the little hiccups there
are uh
so we'll see what happens but uh i i
just think dallas would be crazy to let
dak press got out the door and we'll see
where it goes and dak prescott needs to
be a little flexible himself too at
least in my opinion from what i know
with the whole contract situation
we need to move on to the next question
but this all comes down to the cowboys
not pouncing on the opportunity to get
dak prescott signed to a huge deal but
not a gigantic deal
earlier in the life cycle of his rookie
contract by waiting they have painted
themselves into a corner and dak can
just sit back and say i reject your
offer i'll take 31 million this year and
37.68 million next year i'll do that uh
rather than trade that that ability in
to take whatever long-term deal you're
offering me and until they give him
something that gets him to trade in 69
million over two years he's going to
continue on the path that he's currently
treading all right next question from at
orion chuzz
who do you think could be this season's
browns with the pre-season hype not
matching the results chris who do you
think
well i mean i think the the obvious one
i think of right off the bat is the
tampa bay buccaneers i mean you know
again i think we're all anointing them
like champions right or you know oh
they're going to be in the playoff
conversation and as we know it's just
not as easy uh you know said as it is
done
let alone again hey listen there's still
questions there in tampa bay i mean we
talked it's the worst past defense in
football last year so they're the one
that jumped out but who is the next one
mike because i mean i think you would
agree is the bucks being that team
um who is the next one where we feel
like the hype is starting to outreach
the reality do you have one there
well yeah i do and and you're not going
to agree with me because you're one of
the reasons why the hype has gotten a
little out of control and that's the
buffalo bills i think there's a chance
that they'll take a step back i mean
there's just a chance i mean there's a
chance they won't live up to it how how
many times in the past 25 years have the
bills gone into a season with any type
of expectations the the they're expected
to win the division jim kelly came out
and said i expect them to win the
division and there's that that that
feeling that vibe that they are the best
team now in the division so they only
have one way to go and that's down and
for a team that hasn't won the division
in more than 20 years that that's that's
a lot to carry and i think the bills
have done a much better job than the
browns last year of trying to keep those
expectations from getting out of control
and setting a level that they'll never
match
but i think for me the bills are team
number two on that list i agree with you
buccaneers are number one but the next
one would be the buffalo bills i i
understand that you know i mean they're
one of the teams i wrote down too
you know i just didn't i'm not gonna
pick them as one of my top one or top
two just because you know again i'm
such a believer of brandon bean and sean
mcdermott and how they coach their
football team and just the attitude they
show on a weekly basis just i i just
have a hard time believing they'll lose
their way seems like a very focused
detailed group up there i'll throw one
out you that just jumps out to me a
little bit the denver broncos i know
we've all like talked about them as like
ooh watch out all these new weapons and
vic fangio's defense and all those type
of things hey the afc west is a good
division we know certainly and when you
have that many young players on the
offensive side of the ball sometimes it
does take a little time to gel and
especially with young players and now
learning a new system and pat shurmur
you know that's a real thing this year
unlike most years you know i i think the
offenses that are maybe more intact than
years past have an advantage than the
teams that are bringing in all these new
pieces and trying to make some statement
here in 2020 it's hard to make that
statement when you can't practice all
spring and you know it's limited meeting
time and things like that
and i'll throw one more on the pile the
indianapolis colts you know vegas has
them with the shortest odds to win the
afc south the texans made the playoffs
last year they were in the final eight
the titans were in the final four the
colts didn't make the post season and
they're favored to win the division and
they've got this same issue where you've
got a bunch of new pieces coming in it's
all gotta fall together it's all gotta
work and in a normal year maybe it would
but this is not a normal year and i
think it makes it harder for the colts
to live up to that hype all right at
wilson da10 how do you see the battle of
the four young afc east quarterbacks
playing out this coming season chris
well i i i you know i'm a believer in
buffalo as we just talked about and i'm
buffalo's the leader in the clubhouse to
me in the afc east so i mean if you made
me rank the afc's quarterbacks this year
and you know their success rate
uh
you know
i'm gonna go josh allen jared stidham
sam darnold and then tua down in miami i
think that's the way i see it playing
out more than that you know again i like
what i saw from sam darnold last year
this is not a disrespect to him or
anything like that it's more about just
the jets in general you know i just got
to see more consistent better offensive
play from that whole side of the ball
with the jets i know jared sidham's new
in new england but
you know again it is new england and i
think it's a little bit better of a
receiving core there than people realize
they made a few nice adjustments this
off-season and i i think stylum is
poised and ready to go so uh i'm gonna
give new england instead of a little bit
of the edge over donner on the jets
and you mentioned tuatanga viloa the
dolphins quarterback we've yet to see
any indication that he'll play this year
at all much less start week one i think
it's gonna be ryan fitzpatrick week one
two a probably at some point but chris
you know the the combination of
uh you know the dolphins in this kind of
gradual rebuild process tool with the
hip injury the injury questions and also
with the limited ability to get ready
for the season the idea of throwing him
into the fire aggressively this year
when you have ryan fitzpatrick i don't
know that that makes sense when would
you start tua
well
that that would how does it look in
training camp you know that i say he's
going to be the starter because i think
you know and preseason games is
certainly a big question right now but
if tua shows hey he's poised he's
learning the offense wow he looks like
he's moving good and throwing the ball
well and wow he's clamoring to us that
he wants to play he feels good he wants
to play and then he goes out there and
has a good preseason game or two
there's just i mean the the fan base is
going to be clamoring for him they're
going to be two two what two what we're
seeing with the jersey sales the
dolphins won't have a choice they will
start to that's where i say like you
know if it's a somewhat normal training
camp i think tua will be the week one
starter in miami i do
and and i also think that the dolphins
may do what they did back in 2012 with
ryan tanhail different coaching staff
different everything except owner but
you put the rookie lower on the depth
chart and we've seen other teams do this
where yeah you know he's ultimately
going to win the job
you want him to earn it you want him to
to check the box you want him to develop
the confidence that comes from leap
frogging others on the depth chart right
now you've got not just ryan fitzpatrick
but unless he's traded a release josh
rosen in front of tua as well and maybe
they start him at number three and and
as he shows who he is and what he can do
he works his way up and then when he's
the starter he feels like he's earned it
and the teammates feel like he's earned
it as well so that's right mike
you're definitely right though you're
you're spot on i would think that's
going to be the approach there with
brian flores the next new england guy
too and then you know what they'll do
too is they'll ensure his success
they'll script for success right and
what i mean by that is
they will have certain
certain plays and practice for tua when
he's in there where they're going to run
a certain play on offense and they're
going to make sure that the defense is
in the perfect play to get gashed by tua
and that offensive play so it'll be a
good teaching moment for the defense hey
guys if we get stuck in this defensive
alignment and they call this play okay
we're going to do this but that's what
teams do to build up the momentum of hey
we're trying to make this guy the guy
and get the team to believe and i think
a lot of that will go on with with all
these young quarterbacks but especially
tua down there in miami
interesting question from eric cullison
how often does a team's name play a role
in what people think
of that team for example if you took the
buccaneers roster right now and put them
on the giants the cowboys the packers
etc would they not be considered a top
three team
chris any any credence to the idea that
the name that we apply to a collection
of players influences how we view those
players i i think so i do think there is
something to that the old traditional
powers i feel like get favored a little
bit right if we see any inkling of good
with you know the steelers the giants
the patriots anything like that we just
want to jump onto it the bears same way
like we saw last year so i i do think
there is something to that a little bit
names have power you know hey i used to
say this with the packers all the time i
mean every year we put the packers in oh
they're a super bowl contender they're a
super bowl contender and i wanted to be
like well what about the team tells you
they're a super bowl contender other
than it's the packers and aaron rodgers
so uh i do think there's some truth to
that i don't know about top three team
though like that's that might be
stretching it you know getting more
credit and they deserve yes but i don't
think if brady and everybody was on the
giants we'd be going oh they're a top
three team no i don't think it would be
that drastic
let me ask you this and and setting
aside the coaching staffs just the
players if you took the 53 current
members of the tampa bay buccaneers well
it's 90 but you know what i mean the fit
yiggy yeah i got the ones who are
actually going to play you take the
final 53-man roster and you swap the
buccaneers
and the patriots
are the buccaneers turned patriots with
brady and gronk and mike evans and oj
howard and the pieces they have on
defense under the tutelage of bill
belichick are they not a super bowl
contender right out of the gates
they're going to be yes they're going to
be in the
definitely an upper echelons of that cop
conversation i i agree with you there
yeah
but again you know
that's
matching some proven commodities with
more proven commodities right there it's
like oh okay brady and gronk and bill
belichick all right those are we know
they know how to get it done where you
know again it's not a disrespect to
bruce aryans in tampa bay but just the
reality of the situation is they're not
the new england patriots organization
and you know it's been inconsistent and
bruce aries has had some inconsistent
years coaching football teams so i think
with all of that you know i mean yeah i
agree with you it would be different if
if it was uh the the positions were
swapped there
one more quick one from sage stevens
chris big fan i remember in one of the
madden games i'd always trade for you to
back up jeff garcia on my niners i don't
know if that's a compliment question
whatever happened to the white fur coat
you used to wear to high school parties
this is an important question whoa whoa
watch out i never wore any white fur
coats to a high school party okay i
don't know who this guy is i got to
figure out he's obviously some north
jersey guy who saw me around i did have
a shearling coat my senior year in high
school right you know a shearling coat
like that brown
suede
grow up rich
my dad didn't play quarterback in the
nfl so i don't know what kind of coat
that is oh okay i forgot yeah because
you're not right now you don't know what
those codes look like
you know you know shove it okay florian
give me
[ __ ]
fair upbringing
yes i fear up bringing us he was raised
in his 20 million dollar mansion here
but yes i did have a foot like that and
it wasn't like it was expensive i bought
it off the rack at like nordstrom's or
something like that
the rack at nordstrom's yeah uh okay
that's funny so whatever happened to it
where is it
i it's gone i didn't sport it for a long
time
i loved it it was like you know i kind
of had like that joe namath look to it
it was uh it was pretty good but i don't
know where it's got it's long gone that
was a long time ago
one of the all-time great pre-super bowl
photos your dad with joe namath joe
namath's wearing the fur coat and your
dad's standing there next to him uh
one thinking where's my fur coat but do
you know he set my dad up too he made
sure my dad was gonna wear something
really bland and normal so he can pop he
called my dad a few days before the
super bowl right and hey phil i just
want to know what you're going to wear
so we can kind of be the same and my dad
said no i'm just going to wear a blue
blazer okay okay me too and then of
course he went there and stole the show
and then decided to flip the coin
remember before they said heads and
tails to me one of the all-time classic
pre-game moments of the super bowl
he had a blue blazer on under the fur
coat he wasn't lying yeah
he did he did
all right uh on one last comment from i
don't know 40. you know why do i do this
to myself there's no question he just
says drew pearson didn't push off no
neighbor
i agree i need to track down nate wright
if he's still with us and i'm not sure
that he is and find out what technique
he was playing here when he dives onto
the ground what are you doing the ball
ball's coming in and you dive forward uh
you were pushed that's why you dove
forward so uh it looks like some vikings
so lay bullcrap there just you know just
you know just typical bikes
i don't know why you picked that team to
root for
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports